انا شفت المنظر تبنجت هيك ثانيتين بعدين
رحت جريت عليها كل الناس شردت وانا رحت
عند امي لقيتها رافعه صباعها زي هيك
وبتشاهد وهي اللحظه تم وين راح انا مش
عارف ما حدش كان عارف وين
راح اشتقتلك كثير انت وجاز وبابا
وبستناك وبحبكم كثير
بستناكم
محمد باسم م خريس ابن هاله عبد العاطي
اللي استشهدت في محيط ملعب فلسطين الفيديو
اللي انتشر برصاصه غادره من الاحتلال
الصهيوني بحيث انه هو قالنا انه نطلع ارفع
ريات بيضا وتمر عادي احنا في
يوم 1111 تحصرنا بالدبابات قدنا ليله تمام
هلقيت صاروا يحكوا لنا انه شفنا الناس
صارت تطلع بالشوارع اي فقلنا بدنا نطلع نن
بدنا نتحرك نحن بالبدايه ما تحركنا يعني
ما طلعنا من بيتنا فقلنا بدنا نطلع نا
جهزنا رايتنا البيضاء قبل قبل التحرك
تقريبا كان 20 نفر بس في بيتنا هم احنا
كنا كذا كذا عائله في المنطقه كانت امي
ماسكه ايد تيم وطالعه فيه وانا كنت وراها
بدينا نمشي صار في صوت طخ في الشارع يعني
اول ما بدينا نبين في الشارع ودار خالتي ب
اجوا ودار اخوالي اجوا صار في صوت طخ لحتى
الان عادي يعني طخ على الحيطان كانوا
مشينا هلقيت في ناس بقولوا انه في جندي
كان على الدبابه ماشر لهم انهم يطلعوا
لفوق اذا شفتوا بالفيديو كل الناس طلعت
لفوق انا في وقتها قعدت انادي على امي
اقول لها اطلعي تعالي لهيك تعالي لهيك
فجاه وقعت على الارض هذا اللي انا شفت
يمكن ما
استوعبتش طبعا تيم كان في ايدها وشرد طلع
لفوق انا شفت المنظر تبنجت هيك ثانيتين
بعدين رحت اجريت عليها كل كل الناس شردت
وانا رحت عند امي لقيتها رافعه اصبعها زي
هيك وبتشاهد ما استحملت المنظر حاولت اني
اشيلها كان الحمل علي ثقيل
اي وبزعق ما حدش رد علي او مش مش شايف شي
كنت لحد ما اجا ابويا سندني في حملها
وجريت فيها لحد ما وصلت المفترق ابن
جيراننا ابو يزن حملها عني وجريت على
الدار جراي فتحت الباب دوب وصلت حاولوا
يعملوا لها اسعافات
اوليه كان يعني كانت الرصاصه كثير عامله
فتحه هالقد تقريبا كانت عند القلب
لفوق
استهداف وتعمد اه قناص يعني ما فيش مراه
كبيره وماشيه معها حفيدها ورافعين رايات
بيضا وهي اللحظه تم وين راح انا مش عارف
ما حدش كان عارف وين راح لحد ما اتصلوا
قرايبنا وقالوا انه هو معهم وراحوا على
نصرات بعدين راح على عند اختي على خن يونس
بعدين عند عمه في رفح بعدين اج عننا هنا
كانت على اول الشارع هي امي او انا وامي
اول ناس طلع يعني كنا في مقدمه الناس في
ناس لسه كانت ورا في اول الشارع فهي كانت
ورا لسه هو اللي صار انه لما طخت
الوالده في انا لا انا انا طبعا ما سمعت
ماحدش سامع صوت زنانات خلص جو مخيف ماحدش
شايف شي ولا سامع شي هي مجرد انا ما انطخ
هي كان في ايدها اليمين يعني سبحان الله
زي هيك وقعت على الشمال و وهيك يعني زي ن
تشته قالت له
روح فهو صار يجري وقت حتى انا ما لما شفت
المشهد مش شايف تايم ما شفتش تايم انا رحت
جراي
عليها قبل ما نطلع بعش دقائق كانت تقرا
قران
وتسبح حتى يعني الشيء الوحيد اللي ضللي
منها اهي
سبحته
هذا دائما انا حاملها
معي كانت تسبح
وتدعي تحكي ان عشنا فهنا من اهل الدنيا
وان متنا فاحنا شهداء هذه اخر الحاجات اخر
الكلمات اللي حكتها لاحظت ما شفت الفيديو
تقليب مواجع يعني هو انا خلق المشهد مش
كاين يروح من من راسي بشوفه كل ماج بدي
انام بس انه صار هي كمان موجود فهذا شي
موجع كثير خاصه بالنسبه لاخواتي يعني انا
ممكن اشد على حالي
شويه كل شويه بفتح
اشوفه عشان
[موسيقى]
ادعيلها خلص اضلني يظل الاشي تضلها هي في
بالي
انا كنت يوم السبت رايح
اخطب قبلها بيوم حكت لي امي يوم الجمعه
قالت لي بكره بتروح بتدور على صلاه لو
بدنا نعمل خطوبه وتروح بتعمل فحص كنت مجهز
حالي
و والحمد لله يعني هذا اخر شيء كان قبل
الحرب انه انا رايح اخطب افرح ابسط امي
وحيدها انا
وكنت متخرج جديد يعني كنت متخرج جديد وخلص
امي صارت بدها تخطب لي وانا بقيت بد اخطب
البنت اللي انا
حبها بس خلص قدر الله وهذا امر من الله
وبدنا نصبر
[موسيقى]
يعني